I'll ask you a bearish little bit of
sort of miscommunication that happened
last week where konami z' PR decided to
take their time clarifying something so
telling me a little bit about the sort
of the the elements of microtransactions
that exists in the player-versus-player
aspect of varicella fine so I'm gonna
lay this out by explaining that there
are two multiplayer modes to the game
okay
there's middle gear online that is
coming in October yes it is like two
squads face each other and fight and you
haven't seen haven't played any that
okay the other multiplayer component
that goes live on launch is called fo B
which stands for forward operating base
in the game you manage a base called
mother base forward operating base is a
secondary base that you use to you know
you add more soldiers to your crew there
and they help you develop stuff you can
elect to go into a PvP mode where other
players can invade your base and you can
defend it against them likewise you can
invade other players bases and there's
like a risk reward of different
resources and stuff that come with that
so when I was playing the game I was
playing offline when I got the ability
to build an F OB it said I had to spend
MB coins to purchase the water to make a
place for the babies then said MB coins
are a paid service so to me that said
okay this mode is locked behind a micro
transaction I reached out to Konami
last week days and days ago and said it
looks as though I need to pay money to
access fo B because presumably the MBS
or whatever that currency was supposed
to be something in the game that you
would also earn by doing so no okay
there's so many layers of confusion okay
sorry so you know Konami and said what
are the costs associated with fo B how
do I get it like what are all the steps
their response was oh we'll have more
information for you next week we don't
have anything to share right now they
had that opportunity to tell me I then
put up a news story after playing the
games saying well it looks like that in
order to do fo B you have to buy in B
coins which the game calls a paid
service Konami reached out to me and
said hey that's not true we've said that
in the past and I asked him yesterday
morning again well then give me more
information I need to know how I unlock
this without spending money because I
saw the the screenshot as well from your
we were playing and it says it like
twice yeah this is you need to buy these
and there's no other option
predicts what konami had said in the
past yeah but the fact is I had the
final retail copy of the game and that's
what it was telling me ultimately I
ended up talking to someone else who is
at the review event who was a YouTube
streamer and they played a bill to the
game that was focused on multiplayer and
that was using an internal server by
Konami hmm they play the mission that
unlocks the ability to open up fo B so I
don't understand how this works but
because they were connected online the
game left them by the initial Forward
Operating Base using in-game currency
that they have been earning the whole
time so even though that that's not a
micro transaction connected to a server
they had to be connected to a server for
it to enable them to do that
oh that okay that is weird it's
backwards thinking yeah me being offline
I never got that option so I never saw
evidence of the fact that you get a
forward operating base for free this was
all clarified last night the first fo B
that you can build you can build using
in-game currency every other base after
that you have to purchase using MB coins
I don't know how much they cost Konami
doesn't know yet according to them I
don't know how many MB coins you're
gonna have to spend they still don't
know that either right you can also use
MB coins to speed up development of
certain things as you get to higher
levels bases like new platforms take
like an hour to generate or something
hmm
so as accelerators like games like
whatever you know farmville or but I
have times know you're Solid 5 is
exactly like farmed or [ __ ] on the
box and outside of the the confusion
about yeah and that's sort of the Stila
confusion about exactly what the limits
are on this that can we still haven't
kind of clarified and does that kind of
suck that this stuff is in there like a
solid 5 like it seems almost complete
this what this kind of looks like to me
is that like Kojima made this game and
then this is the bit the Konami French
pop and decided to do this lame Micron's
transaction aspect which seems almost
unnecessary I'm of two minds when it
comes to this issue I mean one I I don't
appreciate micro transactions I mean who
loves them in a full-price game nobody
but at the same time this game
specifically like politics and grand
stances aside what I've played already I
am so satisfied with what I got out of
metal
mmm the f OB stuff being there and that
you can participate in it for free
sounds good to me I played some of it
granted it was on one of the saves from
Konami which was like a really high
level bill so I wasn't attached to what
I was losing or fighting for it was a
fun mode but it's not the sort of thing
I personally want to sink a lot of time
into and I don't know that a lot of
people who are going to really buy this
game are going to be looking for that
specifically either I don't think it's
great I think you know if it's in there
it shouldn't cost any money I'm not
personally bothered by it because I'm
not going to invest a lot of time in it
I think but hey you know if you want to
try it out you can and unfortunately
you're gonna have to spend more money if
you want to get deeper into that and I
can't apologize for anybody doing that
that that's a shitty situation to be in
and you know I wish it wasn't the case
yeah and hopefully it won't be that much
money but I guess time will tell can I
be a lot of snow last question do you
believe just in seeing what they've done
with that that will see some sort of
microtransactions appear in the Metal
Gear Online portion of the game coming
later in the year yeah why not you think
yeah I mean I don't see why I mean look
yeah if there's evidence to support that
they're gonna do it a thing included
with the game at launch
you know I'd be amazed if it wasn't also
a Milla Gear Online
I mean surprise surprise me Konami
surprised us yeah don't surprise us
actually because all the times you've
been surprising some of the passengers
Kojima stuff isn't maybe a bit too much
for our our poor little hearts appear
brand thank you so much for coming on
yeah
you